[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
it's episode 200 something
no idea i got no idea what episode it is
but you know what it is if you clicked
on it because it says on the top of the
[ __ ] i got no he got no idea
christian bale
blow up
he got noah there um so yeah
good for you
um
so yeah we're [ __ ] so scottish good
for yay
um yeah it's episode whatever it is
congratulations we don't know because we
just keep on [ __ ] going and firing on
all syllables and remember we got that
don't push me merch order it now before
my show in phoenix i got phoenix coming
up if you're at the phoenix show you
wear that merch
and uh i clock in i see you there and i
give you a little bit i gave you a
little bit of a wink on stage you got
phoenix coming up on saturday
crystalia.com get those remaining
tickets
uh crystalia.com uh for my phoenix show
uh on saturday april 30th and where that
merch that we got don't push me oops we
got it if you want to support the show
crystallia.com go over on there to go to
get your merch and uh you know what
besides that you know how it'd be you
know how it be dude
um i'm feeling good i'm feeling very
nice you know i've got a really nice
light t-shirt on it might as well just
be made of tissue because it's hot out
dude and i got to keep the [ __ ]
breathing right under it i'm saying
under it i gotta keep it breathing
because i'm not gonna go shirtless
outside like i'm ja rule but i did go
shirtless outside a little bit and your
boy got a little bit of color i know you
can't tell because it takes about eight
days for it to [ __ ] solidify on my
body because of how i'm pasty white and
it's all good
it's all good we all have our things and
we all have our we all have our ups and
we all have our downs and one of my
downs is [ __ ] being being [ __ ] off
death the color off death and it's all
good my babies it is all good have you
checked out our new show called lifeline
me and my brother where we uh we get we
give different advices and that's it
it's the first podcast about you you'll
have to check it out to understand
and um
i mean dude my life is a [ __ ] fairy
tale dude you know like
a good one i guess but it's just like
unreal like i love my life is i love my
life i'm so grateful dude i'm so
grateful i've got a great family my
friends the [ __ ] thickest like just
i'm lucky i get to do what i do and
thank you guys for being my audience and
listening to me like i just i love you
guys man and i so appreciate you and i
love my life and i can't wait to perform
for you and [ __ ] like out on the road
it's just
and my life is great dude and like
um
kristen
texts me
and uh
the nanny right she texts me
hey um
what are you guys doing tonight so my
first thought is uh
uh oh
right she's got a plan
oh no she's got a plan
because you know if there's one thing
you know about me i don't like plans why
fly by the seat of my pants that's what
i do so guess what i don't even know
what i'm doing yet tonight but she asked
what are you doing tonight and since she
asked i have to say i don't know which
means we can do her plan
oh [ __ ]
which means i'm [ __ ] right
so i say where are you and she says
target and i go
oh
double no
these plans involve the shittiest place
in the world
so she says i'll be home in 25 minutes i
have a surprise for tonight
so i know it can't be good if it's in a
group text with the nanny
it might be good if it's just me
but it's not
so i immediately text her back
[ __ ]
what are we building
she haha bubbles it which means
it's confirmed we're building something
so now
i wait for her to get home and i'm in a
good mood my life is wonderful my wife
is wonderful my son is wonderful
honestly the nanny's wonderful honestly
my friends are wonderful
and my house is wonderful and everything
is wonderful right
she gets home and oopsie daisy so many
bags
so we're [ __ ]
i don't know what we're building
but we're [ __ ]
you know what we're building fuckedville
right
so she says you know what i got and i
say
no what and she said i got a projector
and i got a canvas and we're gonna go
outside and set up a bunch of pillows in
the backyard and put this canvas up and
figure out how to do this projector and
bluetooth it to some beats pills and
then we're gonna watch movies
and i go
i say babe we have inside
oh but babe there's inside like that's
this whole thing where it's like it's
the argument is so sound that i can't
get past it right like
we're as far into the future as we are
and everyone lives in homes do you know
why they're better
the people who don't have homes want
homes because homes are better and that
means that outside is cool if you're
like running around and doing daytime
stuff but inside when you're using
technologies like watching tvs or doing
anything that you don't want wind
blowing inside of your mouth
you do it inside cause better
so she's like so by the way she's
amazing at this [ __ ] she's real crafty
and she wants to do it for our son and
that's the thing i'm leading with i'm
like okay well this will be fun with the
sun you know we'll get to [ __ ] watch
movies and he'll get to see [ __ ] so
she hangs this canvas right next to a tv
that we have outside yes we have an
outside tv okay we have a tv outside
that we never really watch but it's
there in case we have a party or
something like that and we have the
canvas next to it that she sets up and
she puts all the pillows down and she
says your only job
is
setting up the projector
and i'm like
you can't use only job when it's 80
percent of the job
none of us set up projectors
putting out a canvas ain't so hard and
throwing some pillows on the rotten
ground ain't so hard either so she's
like all you have to do basically what
you're saying is all you have to do is
open this up figure out where the chords
go figure out how to bluetooth it from a
computer but only visually and then the
sound has to be through an audio source
and i'm just like do we even have a
beats pill i don't know [ __ ] about this
who am i the [ __ ] i don't know how to
do these things right
like i don't know technology who am i
[ __ ] timely jones from that movie
where he's making all those bombs
so
so she sets up all the things i'm like i
don't know how to i don't
and then she walks away
and then she comes back and i like i'm
like i don't know i don't know maybe if
i just wait long enough she'll just do
it you know i you just you know that's
the thing you do as a guy when you're
when you're when your wife or your
girlfriend wants you to do something you
just kind of you look at it long enough
until they're like i'll just hear and
you're like oh yeah i was because i was
trying to you just can trail off a
sentence or two and then
they do it and then they're happy
because
they're upset when they're doing it but
then they end up getting happy because
the things done that they really wanted
so it's like you win it's kind of a win
right
she's like you know what i'll just do it
and then and then i go to hogger and
then she like kind of shies away and i'm
like great she's [ __ ]
yes dude she's pissed dude she's pissed
cause i didn't do the hard part even
though she acted like it was the easy
part
so she sets it all up
and we start watching spider-man and
it's so cute with calvin
and we can't hear it
we can't hear it because it's too
[ __ ] because it's coming through just
the projector we couldn't get the pill
the beats pillow to work
right and i'm [ __ ] and she's watching
it and she's got a [ __ ] [ __ ] eating
grin just like so happy like her smile's
going past her ears and she looks at me
and she says isn't this fun and i said
you know yeah it's [ __ ] cool and i'm
like all bent like because i'm on some
of the pillows you know because if
you're laying on pillows it's all lumpy
and [ __ ] and in my head i'm just like
it's so nice inside because it's the
point
in earth
where we have and humanity where we've
advanced enough to build walls and
electronics and [ __ ] so basically she's
like do you like this isn't it nicer
than inside and now you know me johnny
keeps it real i can't lie
so i say ah you know it's is it nice or
it
it's different and she's like you're
such a see this is and i'm like okay
well okay so she's like why can't you
just be you know i mean she's playful
but she's like you're being just a sour
like and and i'm just like you asked me
i'm not just complaining you asked me so
i'm telling you how i feel about this
[ __ ] and we're watching spiderman by the
way i can't even [ __ ] hear the
goddamn thing and the wind is flapping
the canvas so it's like i need to take a
[ __ ] motion pill a motion sickness
pill
and then we're watching the canvas next
to the [ __ ] tv that's off and i'm
just like
and calvin even chimes in and he says
i know what i want peppa pig on this tv
and i'm like [ __ ] yeah dude
we made another one of me
yeah
[ __ ] yeah dude
it's just like he knows he's gonna know
dude he's gonna know inside's better
than outside
dude if i could do a hike in my house
i'd do it
[ __ ] yeah pull up let's have a tailgate
party in my house pull into the garage
open up and get the exhaust going let's
all die and eat burgers
[ __ ] yeah who you rooting for doesn't
matter we won't even be alive by the
third quarter
who's playing denver bronc
burger in a [ __ ] a hot dog coming out
a snickers in it with a dick vein coming
out hey that looks like
yeah dude
my wife gets so crafty she's so crafty
it's too crafty for her own good man
it's too crafty dude
it's too [ __ ] crafty dude it'll be
like [ __ ] labor day and she'll be
like i got hats
and you're just like for [ __ ] labor
day you have to come on don't be a i'm
walking around with a [ __ ] labor day
hat on
and if i don't wear it i'm a [ __ ]
sour [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] god damn it my lips are all
chapped today too great because of the
wind [ __ ] yeah dude my lips are all
chapped because i watched the new
spider-man outside
there how's that for a sentence and then
dude calvin goes to bed and we start
watching [ __ ] the third season a
servant
probably it's dark as [ __ ] it's so dark
we can't even see it and it's so quiet
because it's a horror movie so
everyone's like i'm some some some it's
like every [ __ ] actor is acting like
the the [ __ ] courtroom in johnny
depp's [ __ ] case
we can't hear [ __ ] and i got and she's
like isn't this great and i'm like i
can't hear him and the wind is flapping
the goddamn thing
lumped up on the pillows she brought out
[ __ ] peanut m ms like anyone eats
them and [ __ ] here
popcorn
anyway watch the whole [ __ ] thing
outside
it's kind of nice
it was nice i mean i get it and she was
like you know what she was like
she was like
this is gonna be you know what it's like
it's not perfect but it's gonna be so
fun like later on these are gonna be the
memories and i'm like [ __ ] it's
memorable if somebody sticks their
finger in your [ __ ] it doesn't mean
you want it and she was like christopher
and i was like what it's true dude
i'm just trying to [ __ ] get to the
point to where i die
you know this way it's just [ __ ] over
this way i can just
chalk it up
oh dude i'm taking the l
that's the thing you know like when
somebody like gets shot and stuff and
they're like take me to the hospital or
whatever or they [ __ ] eat something
that makes their whole body blow up
because they're [ __ ] realized they're
allergic to it dude don't take me to the
hospital that's it i'll take the l man
that was it this was nice peace
that'd be my last words
hey oh no we gotta get to the hospital
no no no no it's all good let me [ __ ]
i'm good with dying and then dying in
this [ __ ] chilis
all good
let me die in this chili's
we didn't know you were allergic to
[ __ ]
fajitas uh turned out it is and then
when i die someone rolls me over and
puts their finger in my ass
[Music]
lips all chapped
and then kristen elise will remember
this red button bunk
i can't believe he died on labor day me
with my hat on
him
but i'm prank gunk
dude
wow
[Laughter]
i went out today i got a coffee and some
dude goes like this man i went out and i
went to go get a coffee you know how i
do it obviously i go out to get [ __ ]
four shots over ice because he graduated
dude he was drinking ice americanos
until he figured out there was too much
water in it and he graduated oh for
[ __ ] sake dude
he keeps getting rougher and harder and
raw and [ __ ] more himself that's what
he does because he got the [ __ ] ice
americano and then he goes like this
water and then he heard
[Music]
thank you very much dude it's been
really great
i've been drinking iced americano for
years and years but now as we look to
the future
i'll i realize this was just diluted
into what my reality should be
[Applause]
so what i'm going to do from here on
forward for the future is is remove the
ice or i'm sorry remove the water
and just have four shots over ice
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
crystalia went on to drink so many
[ __ ] shots over
shots over ice that he [ __ ] died when
he was 42 because he couldn't [ __ ]
take the caffeine
[Applause]
anyway
he graduated fellas and that's what
we're going with
so um yeah man
we have a good time so i got out the
[ __ ] throat mobile and i [ __ ]
actually i was in the blood of guts and
i [ __ ] got out and uh
the security dude on a bike
who
i love making friends with those guys
dude i love making friends with the
security guys on bikes because no matter
what they always have jackets on it
could be 90 [ __ ] eight degrees
they've got to wear all the outfits of
it you know
like they got black slacks and they just
straight up never have t-shirts unless
they're in a beach town if they're in a
beach town for some reason even though
beach towns are [ __ ] colder than [ __ ]
they'll have that white [ __ ] one on
right but if you're in the city of los
angeles no matter what degrees it is
that dude will [ __ ] 100 being a
windbreaker or some [ __ ] and it just
says like they're not cops right they're
just securities on bicycles because by
the way bike cops
pull over
pull over
[Music]
pull over do they do it with their
mouths
isn't that a [ __ ] uh
eddie murphy joke
dude they just [ __ ] pull over i'm all
good dude
no but you have to put no no no no i'm
all good you're on a bike i'm in a car
i mean dude bike cops
you know pathetic
you didn't get the car hey if you're
getting pulled over by a bike cop
don't stop just keep going drive away
right
but dude there's bike security and what
are those guys like flowers they're just
there
like what do they do hey can't do that
all good man
so they get out and they're just
chilling dude i love when the security
just chills man because [ __ ] is mostly
just all good everywhere
uh unless you get into the [ __ ] you
know the really bad neighborhoods and
the dicey areas but dude the guy just
i'm pulling the the the gut that's what
it is the [ __ ] it was the red
interior are so special right and i'm
[ __ ] pulling in and there's always
that lip that bumper lip right but all
my cars they're basically [ __ ] i
gotta you know they're underground right
i mean my cars are [ __ ] crazy low you
know what i'm talking about
so uh
i'm pulling up and i'm doing it i'm
eating forward right i'm trying to
listen to the yip deep deep deep when
that hits because i don't want the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] to get scraped so i started
hearing
it but he's got a camera on the front so
i'm also looking right and the camera
somehow shows up top i don't know how
they're doing it but they're showing me
what it looks like on top of my car
right the shit's so special so i'm
pulling up and it's yeah
i'm looking i'm looking and i notice the
security guy is in front watching he's
watching me so now not only do i not
want to scrape the [ __ ] but i don't want
to look like a punk idiot in front of
the security guard number one i don't
want it to get [ __ ] scuffed on the
bottom but i also i don't want this guy
to see that i'm being a [ __ ] about this
[ __ ] listening to the
watching it from up above
so i stop i get out of the car i'm in
far enough but not too much right i wish
i pulled a little bit further and he
goes like this yo dude i was watching
for you you're all good and i said oh
thanks dude yeah yeah i figured as much
you know and he said yeah you know cause
basically what happens is you pull too
far forward and you'll scrape the front
of it
and i was like
no yeah i know yeah so
but anyway thanks for watching and he's
like yeah because i've been there man
you know
your car most cars are too low and
they'll just scrape it
and i'm like i know dude right and he
says yeah so anyway i was watching you
and i said oh thanks dude
he had that conversation with me
i had to check and see if i was four
different guys
because it was the same conversation
real quick
four times in a row
we did it
dude after the first time
we did it dude
after the first time
but you know i was watching okay yes
thank you
because you know the first [ __ ] god damn
i keep graduating dude we're graduating
past this combo
is this a ged what's going on dude did i
get [ __ ] did i fail math
we did it and there was another bike cop
just chilling in his windbreaker behind
him not saying [ __ ]
so those are the kinds of [ __ ]
experiences i have during the day so
that was the experience i had and i got
the [ __ ] iced americano dry basically
four shots over ice because your boy
walked down the aisle and threw his hat
up and now that's what i'm sipping
i you know i never wanted to graduate
anything i graduated high school but i
didn't graduate college because i
realized how much of a [ __ ] muff up
that was dude don't go to college
and uh who who went to college that you
[ __ ] who who went to peter you didn't
go if p didn't go i'm not going
so um or diddy or whatever his [ __ ]
name is now
dr diddly musk and um
so yeah so um
so that's it
um and uh
and i got the guy and i got the thing
and it's good and we went to the [ __ ]
lot to see our house that we're going to
[ __ ] build uh and we went to the lot
we scanned it all up and we're going to
be able to build a nice [ __ ] lug
cabin right there dude and it's going to
be nice dude went with my fiance and
it's going to be super nice good it was
a nice day they said hey good news i
said what i i've got i show up and the
guy's got a drone just overhead
just taking pictures and [ __ ] of the my
area and the surrounding
part and he was just like the sun sets
in a great place if you want to have a
pool no no i'm like all right cool man
and uh and it was fun it was just
hilarious dude it's so hilarious meeting
guys that just do such different [ __ ]
than you do you know like i go on stage
and i do dick jokes and i do [ __ ]
idiot jokes about my day i do this
podcast and i [ __ ] and this guy
shows up just in a [ __ ] in dockers
and a button down just killing it
looking like he's friends with patrick
bateman with super nice sunglasses real
short hair with gel in it and he's just
like so good news i said what he said so
the sun's going to set beautifully if
you want a pool and another guy's out
there just
with his thumbs dude there was an
assistant that barely talked
and then another short guy dude it was
just unbelievable man
and i'm just like nice nice
and he was like yeah dude you know he
was like my wife said don't don't don't
say anything trying to be funny because
you know
you got a comedian that's a client
and he's just gonna roll his eyes and
then he said to me he said well
um
he said well he said uh what do you say
he said
you know most of my funniest clients are
actually doctors
and i said yeah that's because they're
[ __ ] killing people they gotta be
boom dude it was like i [ __ ] dude it
was like my closer bro the dude just
[ __ ] laughed like hell and i just go
well
if they laugh at my jokes this hard this
is gonna be a [ __ ] smooth process
even though it's going to take three
years
but by the end
trumpet french horn all the horns dude
that one whatever that one is is that
the french horn
the one that sounds like eminem
um
so that's what's up dude and uh
and we stay doubling it i'm gonna double
it until they kill me so um
you know
it's the first day i got a [ __ ]
tattoo this is like the third day i
still got the [ __ ] thing on i got a
triceratops i made it i made a a video
of it it's coming out on monday look at
that darkness look at that beautiful
darkness
it makes his skin look extra white but
it's all good it's new so it looks extra
dark but look at that darkness dude and
he shaved it so it looks like it pops
right because they shave it that's the
worst part of the tattoo they shave it
first and then you look like a [ __ ]
chump
and you get that little section of
[ __ ] hair that's not shaved and
people are like oh are you are you dying
and you're like no i just got a [ __ ]
tattoo of a
of a butterfly
why i don't i don't really honestly know
and um
text them to turn that lower and then um
yeah they're watching the [ __ ] johnny
depp trial [ __ ] all day er all day
dude my girl's watching the john depp
trial anyway i'll talk about this then
i'll talk about the johnny depp trial
but the [ __ ] uh yeah i got this
tattoo and i was going to irvine to to
[ __ ] go to the
place
to do it because this guy was a fan he
came to my irvine show let me look let
me look him up so i don't get any of any
of this [ __ ] wrong but he gave me this
tattoo
um
[Music]
devon mena tattoos on instagram and uh
yeah he did that [ __ ] he did it i i
said to my son i said what's your
favorite dinosaur and he said i sell
tops and i said okay would you want me
to get a tattoo of a triceratops and he
said yeah
and i said well what do you want um what
do you want to uh
what what's your favorite uh i said
where would you want me to get it and he
said
arm so i was like okay you want me to
get right there so i got it right there
i got the skull right there and then he
was looking at it
oh and then so i was like so i'm gonna
go get it and and it was the first day
dude it was on a saturday because i
wanted to [ __ ] drive out to irvine so
well it was uh what do you call it um
[Music]
the weekday and i'm in [ __ ] i'm and i
go to leave early and it's like gonna be
a a beautiful day like my son got a set
we put a sandbox together almost threw
up we put a sandbox together and he was
playing with his water table and [ __ ]
and i had to go get the tattoo and and
he says uh and i say all right calvin i
gotta go
i gotta go today cause i'm gonna go get
that tattoo and i don't know if he knows
what i'm talking about but it was the
first day that he goes like this
oh oh i i love you so much daddy
and i was like oh
no
this is gonna be hard
it was the first day where he was just
like oh yeah they leave sometimes
bro just a week ago [ __ ] kristen left
for five days and and calvin was like
mom who
and now i'm like i gotta go get a tattoo
for three hours and he goes like he
literally shrugged his shoulders and
made a sour puss and he goes oh
okay dad i love you so much and i was
like oh oh it's gonna be me that's the
first one that feels this
so now it's like [ __ ]
which only means one thing he [ __ ]
loves me more dude [ __ ] yeah man my son
loves me more [ __ ] yeah dude
thanks calvin
[Music]
he misses me dude so then i came back i
showed him the tattoo you got to see
this with chris video it's so [ __ ]
cute dude he looked at it and he was
like i said to yx and i was like do you
want to get a tattoo or no that's a
sarah ceratops i said yeah i said do you
want to get a dinosaur tattoo i said
yeah i said of what and he said tx like
that dude and my heart just goes [ __ ]
ugh
[Music]
so it's [ __ ] beautiful man to be a
dad and i suggest that if you're
thinking about becoming a father
absolutely splurting her
um
so yeah dude just i'm just saying if
you're thinking about becoming a father
and maybe not necessarily but you're
unsure of it just [ __ ] remain ron
splurtner you know what i'm saying dude
that's all i'm saying right like if
you're like should i or should i not
it's going to change my life is it going
to be for the better or for the worse
mostly for the better so just tear it
off and splurten her it's all i'm saying
that dick be a geyser and it will be
beautiful make your dick a geyser and
that [ __ ]
will change your life dude
um so yeah
and it's uh and so it was so cute man i
love being a dad for real um
[Music]
and uh
i got the tattoo and it was nice dude
i got that that too i got in the [ __ ]
tattoo parlor how come tattooed parlor's
always got like [ __ ] tits all around
everywhere like just cartoon tits
everywhere
so [ __ ] weird you go to a tattoo
parlor what is it about [ __ ] tattoos
and tits people don't even really get
their titties tattooed that much but you
go to a [ __ ] tattoo parlor there will
be like [ __ ] chicks like drawing
drawings of chicks just like this with
tits out and then also there will just
there will be literally pictures of just
tits
you know how [ __ ] weird that is
tattoo guys
hey i hate that too guys stop hanging up
just tits on your wall
dude
just be like a [ __ ] like just from
here down and a girl's pulling a shirt
up and just tits the tits won't even be
tattooed dude
imagine if other establishments did that
you go to mcdonald's and they were just
tits out yeah let me get a number two
and then what do you want honey number
eight oh nice tits uh let me supersize
the
just tits everywhere you go to [ __ ]
ikea
buying furniture near just tits
just going to kinko's making some copies
next to just tits
um just some tits for no reason
on the way out to get my tattoo i
[ __ ] had to get gas
and my my house has a um
my house has a uh what do you call it uh
a patio
and uh oh god let me [ __ ] text him to
do it lower
hey guys turn it lower
um
[ __ ] goddamn pay attention to your
phone for once you know kristin goes
like this how christian texts this is
how kristin texts hey what do you want
for dinner
i'm walking on sunshine and the [ __ ]
phone and for three years it's just on
the ground
and i'm right yep i'm i'm whatever it is
turkey meatloaf turkey turkey meatloaf
question question turkey meatloaf is
that good okay not that then you want to
do some chicken and she's just i'm
walking on sunshine oh
it's so annoying dude she just goes like
this hey what's it called when you
[ __ ] do do phone [ __ ] blump up in
her anus for six years walking around
farting on her phone and i'm trying to
call her
in her anus where's my phone
it's so [ __ ] annoying
jesus christ sometimes we got [ __ ] to
say
she's walking around a park just her
phone's at the library she's just
walking around a park for no reason
where where are you well wherever my
phone's not
so [ __ ] no dude i'm gonna tether that
phone to calvin he's not growing up like
her dude i'm gonna put a little i'm
gonna i'm gonna go to that two piercing
place and i'm gonna [ __ ]
open up a little part of my son so his
phone could stick in it like a shirt
pocket
dude it's so [ __ ] i'm gonna i tell
you right now dude
and every time you go to a tattoo place
too
there's the piercings guy and the tattoo
guy
and i go to the [ __ ] and the
piercings that's just like a body
modification [ __ ] is just
it's just i don't know you know about it
it's like you get the guys with the
[ __ ] big saucers in their ears
or like just
some guy goes in there and they got like
lumps like [ __ ] four lumps that just
were like are scar tissue
discarification and [ __ ]
it's just so weird to me
or they just got some guy goes in hey
how much is it to just lop my arm off
what yeah this is a this is a body mod
place right yeah how much to lop my arm
off am i not speaking english i'm sorry
can you just [ __ ]
slit my tongue please
like what kind of a lunatic you have to
be to just yeah [ __ ] slip my tongue
and ink up my eyeballs
[ __ ] life right
dude people just [ __ ]
slit up their tongue and ink up their
eyebrow their eye their eyeballs just
black and [ __ ] if i was gonna get by the
way if you're gonna get [ __ ] eyeballs
tattooed for real go red you [ __ ]
these [ __ ] out there darkening
up their eyes going black oh bro you
really bowed about it get red eyes dude
what the [ __ ]
i mean how could you do it but if you're
gonna do it red eyes
um
so yeah uh
so yeah [ __ ] i got the triceratops
and there were [ __ ] tits everywhere
in the tattoo shop and then i go there
and it was great and it was all good
and then he goes like this
i go like this how much
and he goes
well how about a trade
and i go like this very interesting
what's the trade
and he says
will you tattoo me
and i go
i say
what
and he says
will you give me a tattoo and i said
i don't do that and he said
even better
dude some about these [ __ ] tattoo
guys they just don't give a [ __ ]
you know
what do you want to do today put a dick
on my back
what do you want to do today
yeah let's get a pig tattoo [ __ ] it
and um
and i did i tattooed life rips on his
arm dude
the dalia original that's the [ __ ]
dalia ridge tattoo the original
so now i do tattoos guys if you want a
tattoo honestly it's five thousand
dollars and i'll do it and i only do
life reps and that's it i'll do anything
actually for five thousand dollars i
don't care i'll do any tattoo you want
for five thousand dollars and that's it
i will not do it for any [ __ ] less
than that i won't do it for four
thousand nine hundred dollars
um
so
i'm a tattoo artist
[ __ ] she won't stop watching the
goddamn johnny depp trial it's like it's
[ __ ]
it's like it's it's like it's a child of
hers
it's unbelievable
johnny depp on the stand just so smug we
love him though don't we
johnny depp we love him though don't we
yeah we do dude and if you [ __ ] if
you believe amber heard oh dude boo
it was obvious what she was doing
[ __ ] six days after she wrote her
[ __ ] op-ed he lost parts of the
caribbean boo
he lost fantastic beasts it doesn't
matter that much because that movie
sucks but
he lost two franchises because of the
op-ed by uh [ __ ] what's her name
austin
heard boo
and she's aquaman dude and zack snyder
kept her in even though she was like
[Applause]
aquaman dude and she's [ __ ] now she's
getting all exposed because johnny
depp's smug as [ __ ] dude trust me when i
say you do not want to do a trial when a
guy who's gonna be on the stand as
acting in his corner
cause the dude knows you know what he
knows see you see amber heard in the
[ __ ] box and [ __ ] you see her behind
the desk and she's all
like she can't uh she thinks she's
acting but johnny depp knows something
that she doesn't
stillness
dude do you see how he's serving the
[ __ ] lawyers
the lawyer come up and they're all cocky
you know her hollywood shits well didn't
you say this and he goes like this
yes
okay but then this and that's what you
said right
yes
okay and again you said this
for the third time yes
okay and then okay and then that's this
right that's when you said this
i'm sorry you're asking about which one
you're asking about the other
a different thing or the same three
things you just asked for the fourth
time yes okay
oh dude and the courtroom goes like this
everyone in court like this ever in the
courtroom like this
he's so still
he's still almost open here amber hurt
is twitching
and then every [ __ ] recording that
was [ __ ] up
because they don't show the whole thing
in the [ __ ] news in the media they
don't show the whole thing when the
whole [ __ ] thing went down because
[ __ ] amber heard just shows clips and
[ __ ]
and then they show the whole recording
and she's like and the recording starts
and she was like remember johnny when
you wanted to fight and it was your idea
and then [ __ ] johnny depp's like um
you know i i don't know i guess i'm oh
she's like right you started everything
admit it
um
[Music]
and then the lawyer's like you smashed a
cupboard huh and he was like
sometimes you get mad and you smash a
cupboard
the [ __ ] jury even
still
acting in this car
just get exposed
[Music]
do you want to call under
you want to call an order
and then he shows up in a suit and she
wears the same thing the next day you
see that [ __ ] that [ __ ] creep dude
i'm glad dude so many guys are getting
accused of this [ __ ] so many guys
are getting accused of this stuff and
everyone's scared to speak out and then
johnny depp is just like i've got 800
million dollars i've got the time
i am not in two franchises anymore
play the whole recording everyone
in the jury
this was still he's got acting in this
corner
i mean dude it's like
oh man
so that's what it is so [ __ ] she's
glued to the tv watching the [ __ ] you
know
cause uh
it's you know that's what it is
[Music]
johnny depp dude you better not you're
you know i know it's the [ __ ] money
thing it sucks you didn't get those
[ __ ] parts of penzance movies or
whatever the [ __ ] but honestly dude
that's those [ __ ] movies like you
don't need to do that [ __ ] you're beyond
that it becomes a point where you're
just beyond that you've done all the
great [ __ ] johnny depp did all the great
[ __ ] i wasn't a [ __ ] fan of johnny
depp till now by the way i mean i liked
him fine but now that courtroom acting
that stillness dude and say what no just
know when he's right
yeah
it's a weird thing what what what this
media wants to do the narratives that
they want to push
case in point um so
yeah
oh so that's what i was gonna say so i
went to go get this tattoo
and [ __ ]
i went to go get this tattoo and my car
is on a
is on the driveway and there's a patio
overhang and my dogs were out there all
day and when i go to get gas because i
wanted i need to get gas in my [ __ ]
car and i got out of the cast got out of
the uh car they pumped the gas i looked
in the hood of the car
bright yellow
all over the hood of my car splashed on
it and let me tell you right now
couldn't be none but piss
couldn't be none but piss
one of my dogs [ __ ]
ripped his leg up
on a pole on the patio and [ __ ]
leaked all over my car dude and when you
see that yellow substance couldn't be
nothing but piss
i mean dude i'm driving around with a
[ __ ] piss mobile so it's got blood
and piss on it dude called the cops
so the [ __ ] piss is all over and i'm
like for [ __ ] sake dude i gotta drive
so long to go to [ __ ] irvine
and so
so i pull i i i was like how do i clean
it you know i don't have my [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and so i used the little
window thing that they have at the gas
station i didn't know if you could do it
on the [ __ ] mat paint but i didn't it
was fine so he [ __ ] got out of that
one yes dude he didn't have a piss
mobile for long
so um
so that's it dude but my dogs are pieces
of [ __ ] man you know [ __ ] don't get dogs
i mean i love dogs i have four dogs but
don't get dogs dude they piss and [ __ ]
everywhere you gotta teach them and
stuff why do you want more things to
teach a son is cool though um
so yeah
i love how they [ __ ] tried to show
johnny depp's text messages in the court
like it was evidence against him he was
texting with like paul bettany which is
hilarious that he was texting with paul
bettany by the way
and and he was just texting like how
[ __ ] callan and i would text like oh
no she's a she's i think she's a witch
and paul dent and he's like no she's
probably not a witch he's like we should
burn her at the stake shouldn't we ha ha
and he's like no we shouldn't and then
the [ __ ] lawyer does it all out of
context and he's just like so you're
admitting that amber you think amber
heard was a soulless witch and i'm sorry
but you wanted to burn her at the stake
and johnny depp's just like it wasn't
just what's that
so still
this guy actually in this corner
dude you [ __ ] master there should be
master class in court with johnny
with johnny depp dude master class they
have martin scorsese for directing
[ __ ] uh some race car driver for
drifting and then johnny depp for
in-court master class
hi class i'd like to tell you first of
all we'd like to teach the first thing
which is stillness don't move unless you
have to and wear a bug on your tie
that's step two
um
so yeah
i don't know what's going on elon musk
is buying twitter is that a good thing
or a bad thing who knows everything's
going to [ __ ] yay dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
twitter was bad
the only thing that makes it worse were
swords
is it a megalomaniac
da
[Applause]
the
billion dollars
[Applause]
i hope they make everybody
know who everybody is i can't stand this
anonymous [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can't stand anonymous [ __ ] tweet
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
everybody should know they should all be
exposed for who they really are and
retroactively too so we get to see all
the [ __ ] they're coming after
celebrities for racist tweets and [ __ ]
they're coming out [ __ ] the producer
of jeopardy for [ __ ] saying the
n-word or whatever oh yeah what'd you do
dude
and now we know dude
um
bro sometimes i just know what's up i
was at the [ __ ] i was with uh
woke up real down today by the way i
woke up real real down and real dark and
[ __ ] emotional and [ __ ] now i feel
better because of this podcast thanks
very much had a black cloud over my head
now it's a little bit grayer so i
appreciate you guys just listening
um
yeah
so some days were a struggle so
[Music]
you know one thing rest assured though i
always know what [ __ ] program to
watch that's for fetch for real dude i
always know like my buddy came over mike
with his [ __ ] girlfriend and i was my
fiance
and they were just we got home mike and
i got home and they were talking about
you know they were talking about stuff
just you know how sometimes chicks
honestly just talk about stuff dude
like they'll just be like and then what
did he say and you're just like what
i don't know it already happened
you know
hmm you know what we should do for and
you're just like what look here let's
just have this fake conversation because
it's not gonna materialize not even
because of me because you're gonna
either forget about it tomorrow because
you're drunk right now or in a year
you're just not gunwanna
we should just fix up an old car
really what kind of car i don't know
like there's old cars and i just
you don't even know what do you know
what that entails no do you
no well then
dude just [ __ ] shoot an arrow through
my chest
i want to watch my blood come out my
mouth
so
and just
blood spatting against your chin
and then one of these coughs
chris are you okay
dude i bet that sounds real dope on
audio only um
so we got home and they were talking and
i just said like i said something you
know
and i just said something i don't even
remember what it was and then mike came
in and mike's always like coming in
looking in my fridge like he's a [ __ ]
neighbor in a sitcom and he opens up the
fridge and he's just like yeah you guys
got [ __ ] hey look at this hello mane
and i'm just like bro we didn't say
that's calvin's you know and he's like
he's like halfway done
anyway so we get in and i come in and i
ask i'm asking you know you know when
you when you arrive into a house into an
area where people already are you don't
know what energy they're in so you've
got to match their energy but it takes a
little while and here's something that's
just totally true my fiance doesn't
realize that that's a thing all good but
i'm gonna come in the way i came in with
my energy and her energy is already
there and guess what her energy is with
her with her girlfriend right
serene serena [ __ ] why because two
chicks drinking white wine really
feeling themselves you know what i mean
just watching some [ __ ] on tv like the
johnny depp trial you know what it's
interesting because and here i come in
stomp stomp stomp stomp with my energy
and i'm just like hey did you guys order
anything or we should order some food
and already i feel the eyes rolling back
into her head you know what i'm talking
about and i know the energy but now i
can't stop it because i'm like a bit of
a juggernaut myself right and then mike
comes in he's got his own energy and
he's already looking in the fridge and
he's like what are you guys doing you
want to turn something on and and
they're just both like what this energy
whatever this energy is you need to just
and i'm just like yeah but you got to
respect the [ __ ]
you know what i mean
the the the
space to match the energy
i got to realize what energy you're on
and we got in a little bit of a not not
an argument at all but we were just
talking about energies and [ __ ]
and then i was like i got an idea and i
turned on youtube and i [ __ ] fixed
everything by turning on a [ __ ]
special on fentanyl by national
geographic [ __ ] yeah dude
oh it was so [ __ ] dope man it was
like taking an ecstasy pill because
everyone was like i don't know and we
just popped that [ __ ] national
geographic tone pill in on the tv and
they just for a little bit we're just
like i don't i mean just
but five minutes in we were zeroed in
even mike was like this is not the thing
to watch dude five minutes in we were
zeroed in learning all about fentanyl
and the problem man
i mean dude
we know how to make that [ __ ] now we
know how to [ __ ] sell it we know
where to go to buy it we know how many
people are dying
a day
so many by the way
and uh and we watched the whole thing
dude
but it was like one of those
investigated journal you know it's like
you know
it was one of those journalists that was
like can't stop telling you that they're
a journalist you know it was like a 40
year old woman that's just like being a
journalist i've been in some sticky
situations as a journalist and i went to
ger i went to a places journalist and a
journalist and i was in asia and this is
and this is coming from me a journalist
who was in the underbelly they're always
in the underbelly of something you know
it's never on the [ __ ] regular belly
or above the belly it's always and this
is the underbelly of crime in in newark
that we don't know that we haven't seen
and that we we were the [ __ ]
as a journalist
and so i'm following this journalist
around and she's like dude
some of these journalists they just want
to get capped you know what i mean they
just want to get a [ __ ] bullet to
their head a stray bullet from a
neighborhood
from a bad guy that they're not even
interviewing dude the way they go in
they're like first of all why it's like
we know fentanyl is bad i know fentanyl
is bad and guess what awareness is great
i saw this documentary and maybe
fentanyl is even worse than i thought
but
are you a guy like me watching a
documentary and then that's it
people talk about awareness like it's
great but really awareness is nothing
because you're just sitting on the couch
eating a bag of [ __ ] funyuns
and then after the documentary is over
you go to sleep you wake up the next day
and you [ __ ] you just go to the
[ __ ] supermarket you drop your kids
off you're not thinking about fentanyl
anymore you don't do anything to help
awareness is great but if that's all it
is
you're a sucker
so these journalists they got a [ __ ]
death wish you know they're going into
these [ __ ]
and they go in and she goes into the
so so the first question is journalists
what are you doing
doing okay and the second question is
hey crooks
why are you inviting the camera crew in
you're gonna get caught and they [ __ ]
got the you know the gas or the either a
gas mask because they're making
meth or some [ __ ] or a ski mask and a
[ __ ] goggles and [ __ ] and like their
voice changer just like well what we do
is we get the [ __ ] from cuba
and then we make it i'm a termites
basically i'm a chemist i've got it and
they just are you dude you're gonna get
caught i don't understand
i i don't understand it and i'll never
understand it
like the film crew like these dudes are
just okay with the film like footed do
they get final cut
like are they like you know we wanted
can you send us a dropbox link a dropbox
links before you've put it to national
geographic please
just like this is journalist yeah
can you just can we do
you can totally follow us we're gonna
kill three guys that owe us money um
do you mind can we see final cut before
you expose our underbelly
yes there's a journalist's code there's
a journalist code
and then they talk about the journalist
code like in war like you can't shoot
the journalist or whatever [ __ ] that
dude if i'm at war everybody's dying
people are like no not [ __ ]
no not regular people who just live it
dude everyone's getting it man if i have
a war
against me
bro i've seen a little bit too much
tupac to not go out guns blazing for
real i watched a documentary on tupac
once and he was just like yeah i got the
ak-47 and i got these [ __ ] guns
because when i said it in that song i
ain't going back to jail i'm in it
the cops coming for me i'm i'm [ __ ]
lighting them up and i was just like he
speaks to me yeah i'm a boy from la
canada but he speaks to me
um
yeah dude
so these documentaries really make you
feel some type of way for about three
hours and then you go to sleep and then
just go on with your life the next day
um
i just don't understand how these crooks
are just like okay
imagine the [ __ ] bank robbers just
did it they were just like sure come on
let's go so today we're about so today
we're actually going to rob a bank of
america
and uh the journalist is just like so
when you're in the mind frame of going
into like dude this is how crazy it is
they're literally at the [ __ ] table
they're they're making these drugs to
sell and they're like you know people
die from this right and they're always
it's you know it's not my job to uh to
make sure people do what they want i
just make the product and or they or
they [ __ ] compartmentalize and
they're just like well they're
definitely not dying on my [ __ ] because
my stuff is all made very pure and very
great uh now as for selling it and they
turn it into what they turn it into then
they can die that way but it's not you
know
phoenix
gonna be in phoenix april 30th
what's up with this [ __ ] i gotta i
gotta see the snickers dick vane thing
this is the
hilario this is
fact check woke mob did not remove the
dick vein from snickers bar there's a
[ __ ] 2022 title
woke mob did not remove the dick vein
from snickers bars
so
i mean
this is a real
thing that woke people
you'd be this is from boingboing.net
you'd be forgiven if you never noticed
the similarities between the lumpy
chocolate seam that tops off the
snickers candy bar and the infamously
throbbable dorsal vein that adorns the
human penis k i mean who wrote this
[ __ ] patrick bateman
you'd be forgiven if you never noticed
the similarities between the lumpy
chocolate seam that tops off of the
snickers candy bar and the infamously
throbbable dorsal vein that adorns the
human penis
um
oh yeah because they did the sexy uh
green eminem scandal of 2022. um
mars company there is a rumors
that the mars company had also
redesigned the snickers bar to better
fit with some imaginary set of woke mob
standards and doing oh so they were
saying
that they
made it seem like snickers
downplayed
the throbbable dorsal vein
on the snickers i mean
and then
this
so this imposter content was published
snickers are officially caving and
removing the world renowned dick vein
from the candy bar by the way i never
knew about this at all until this
dude if you're looking at a snickers bar
and you're like huh [ __ ]
you know
he got probs
it's not like [ __ ] like people are
eating it like this
oh [ __ ] yeah dude
snicker satisfies or whatever the
[ __ ] thing
is that what it is
snickers satisfies dude you're not even
eating it
what the [ __ ] it looks like you're
jerking it off on your hey that looks
like a dick vein what you know the
throbbable one
dude chill out let me just [ __ ] eat
my snickers
what the [ __ ] hey that looks like a
dorsal vein what's that
you know the thing on the top of your
dick that starts throbbing when you get
super hard
hey
we're awful
if you get rid of that friend
that [ __ ] thinks
and so anyway they're not removing it
okay so they cleared that up so thanks
snickers dude thanks snickers seriously
there's probably do wonders for their
[ __ ]
i mean there's definitely dudes that put
stickers in their buttholes you know
it's funny because when you [ __ ]
[ __ ] it out it looks the same
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] fact that it wasn't on the
thing and it goes bloomp first
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] man
dick vayne man i know a guy with a crazy
big dick van it's unbelievable it's
actually unbelievable
i don't have a crazy big dick vein but
holy [ __ ] dude
my buddy's got the craziest biggest dick
vayne it's unbelievable
anyway
ah let's look at this spider-man falls
off roof and continues playing accordion
i mean what on earth could this even be
love it
oh no
oh
[Music]
dude
just hanging himself
dude the best part about that is
the sound of the accordion is what
happens when a cartoon [ __ ] falls and
gets up anyway
do you know what i mean
it's like
like it was already he had it
he's so out of it dude he's so out of it
that he just keeps playing it's like
that [ __ ] that that karate guy that
does the flip and then gets up and keeps
going you know which one i'm talking
about it's [ __ ] old [ __ ] let's play
it again
wow spider-man you know
hey guy don't do this you're not
spider-man
we tried to watch spider-man with my son
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it was so cute
because chris didn't hear let's play it
again
the most
does he let go bro
oh my god still was kind of good ripping
it dude this was [ __ ] i love how the
account is acceptable videos
so not [ __ ] uh
believing in itself well you know
they're acceptable
hey guys that's the episode for youtube
if you want to catch the rest of the
episode on uh patreon you can the uncut
raw
rough rugged episode um
on
patreon.comcristalia and you can also
get our other shows that we do
uh which is
review mode and also uh all of the other
past patreon episodes because we have
one a month and we've been doing this
for over a year now so uh yeah we have
like 12 episodes of patreon
and i'm gonna go uh throw up in my mouth
a little bit so patreon.comcrystalia
binge binge it go to get the patreon and
binge the episode see you guys
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you